what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder and Shazam 2 Fury
of the Gods is 10 days away now there
has been so much that has been said
about this movie recently and there have
been a lot of talks on whether or not
Zachary Levi is going to be sticking
around in the new DCU under the Helm of
James Gunn to continue to play his
character Shazam so a lot of talk going
around which will break down but also
the reviews for the film are now out
from the critics and the people who
attended the world premiere for the
movie the Embargo is now over and people
are giving us their thoughts on what
they thought of the movie truly and it's
actually quite surprising lately some
insiders online have been talking about
how they heard the movie isn't exactly
good they've also expressed how they
think that the difference between Billy
Batson and Shazam himself are very
different and that doesn't really make
sense basically people have already been
kind of picking out the movie before
they even had a chance to see it which
makes these reviews so shocking because
a lot of them are really good for
example take this one from Anthony over
at the movie podcast he says Shazam Fury
of the Gods is exhilarating David F
Sandberg whips up a captivating and
truly funny story that can be celebrated
with the whole family Rachel zegler Jack
Dylan Grazer and Digimon hunzo are
standouts for me fury of the Gods is
super powered fun so exhilarating
captivating and funny and then at the
end he says it's fun and we're gonna get
to what that actually means in a second
but let's look at a few more real quick
Eric Eisenberg over at Cinema Bland
stated Shazam theory of the Gods is a
super fun and worthy sequel not a
game-changing comic book movie but it
wins you over with its characters and
energy has some real surprises and a
knowing sensibility that suit it well
plus some creative and exciting monster
action so this one right here seems like
a more grounded reaction essentially
stating that it's not a game changer for
comic book movies but I'm not sure
anybody was really expecting it to be
it's not like this is an Avengers
Infinity war or Avengers in-game level
event it's not the next Justice League
film so definitely do not go in with any
of those expectations at all if you want
to enjoy this film but we continue to
hear positive reviews from varieties
Courtney Howard she states Shazam Fury
of the Gods shazam movie is a super
powered sequel that packs a punch a
super solid super fun and super smart
blend of hilarity heart and heroics
ramps up the actioned and reverence to a
delightful degree Helen Mirren Lucy Leo
and Rachel zegler are nvps love the
dragon so another review basically
stating that this is a solid movie and
that it's super fun plus it has some
heart to it and a lot of reviews are
actually stating that this is indeed
better than the first movie which is
great because I personally did enjoy the
first movie so that means I should enjoy
this one Daniel Baptista over at the
movie podcast States Shazam Fury of the
Gods is magical and hilarious family
adventure David F Sandberg supercharges
everything that made the first film
special with the heart of the story
always the shazamly Rachel zegler and
Jack Dylan Grazer steal every scene now
what's interesting is this is more
praise for other actors in This film but
we haven't really heard anything about
Zachary Levi a lot of the reviews are
praising other actors but not Zachary
Levi himself and there are some reviews
out there from people who didn't like
the movie digital spies Gabriella
Geisinger said this within Shazam Fury
of the Gods is a fun buddy comedy
starring Digimon hunso and Jack Dylan
Grazer unfortunately you have to watch
Shazam 2 to see it few bright spots
bogged down by Final Act muddy CGI
battle Evie plays Billy as if he's in on
the joke and uncanny valley of humor so
not a good review and not a good review
of Zachary Levi's portrayal of Shazam
however there are counters to this for
people who were really looking forward
to this movie and are big fans of Shazam
this is what fans of Shazam have said
the illuminaries Joseph deckelmeyer said
this Shazam Fury of the Gods is what I
wanted the movie to be the film does a
good job of balancing this large cast
and it's just a fun superhero movie with
a lot of heart I'd love to see these
characters and actors carry on in the
DCU and I think it can fit it go see it
or yourself so here's something to
notice about most of these reviews and
also please keep in mind that these
reviews should not influence your own
opinion of the movie do not let them
hold you back from going to the movies
go see it for yourself and form your own
opinion please a lot of these reviews
are good they state that the movie is
fun it's full of heart it's got good
energy and it's probably just going to
be a good time at a good superhero film
however it's not going to be anything
super spectacular there were a few
people who said that the movie was
wonderful and exactly what they wanted
it to be however I'm not seeing a lot of
wow this movie was great this movie was
fantastic but we're seeing a lot of this
movie is fun it's kind of like how I
felt for Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and I think a lot of fans as
well when people went in and just said
yeah it was a fun movie it wasn't
anything special it really actually
wasn't on a super big scale however it
was funny it was heartfelt and it was a
fun movie that's kind of what I'm
hearing for Shazam 2 here now the cast
alone is enough to make you want to go
and watch this movie the first Shazam
was really kind of just about Shazam
Zachary Levi's portrayal of him and of
course there was some heart thrown in
there with his foster family and it
sounds like in this film they really
dive deeper into that aspect and then of
course when you have Helen Marin and
Lucy Liu as the villains you know
they're going to be great they are two
wonderful actors they are fantastic they
are seasoned veterans who know how to do
their jobs and they're both so
charismatic and Charming you already
knew they were going to crush it and
they are getting a lot of Praise so the
villains are good or at least the
actings for the villain characters are
good so most of these reviews seem to
come in in about at a 70 percent a
eighty percent so like a c like a b
movie now some of course are going to
say it's an A plus plus and some are
going to say it's an F minus go see it
for yourself but the fact that people
are indeed saying that it's pretty
decent and a solid movie makes you
question whether or not Zachary Levi is
going to stick around for the new DCU
well based on the comics that Zachary
Levi has stated recently at this point
in time it's looking like he probably
won't be playing Shazam now James Gunn
has already stated that some characters
are still up for debate he still doesn't
know if some characters are sticking
around Wonder Woman is a perfect example
and Gal Gadot playing Wonder Woman James
Gunn has openly admitted that he's not
sure what they're going to do there and
that he's had conversations with gal I
think this might be kind of a similar
case for Zachary Levi's Shazam a few of
the reactions and I mentioned one state
that they would love for the character
to stay inside of the DCU however when
Zachary Levi recently spoke up about
this he did say that he wants the
character to stay even if he is not the
one to play the character so when he
said that a lot of people thought well
he might have already met with James
Gunn and James Gunn might have already
told him that yeah the new DCU is going
to move on without him but knowing James
Gunn and knowing how open he is about
everything that is going to happen with
the DCU he will probably comment on this
pretty soon maybe once Shazam has been
out for a couple of weeks or a month
maybe he'll wait till then maybe he's
trying to gauge the audience's reaction
to see if they truly do like this
character and like the movies either way
I'm sure he will address this soon the
same thing goes for a Gal Gadot and some
other characters like Jason Momo's
Aquaman but in the meantime Shazam Fury
of the Gods comes out in 10 Days please
be sure to go watch the movie if you are
interested and let us know your thoughts
whether that be on Twitter or in the
comment section of some of our videos
thank you all for watching this video
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DCU news and you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign